welcome to this video playing vollmer
fia's 88 again from spain many guys from
spain at the moment mmhmm yeah the
Slovaks change not exactly something
that something that sends shivers down
your spine queen bee three yeah that's a
very direct way to exchange stuff I can
take the form maybe I should but okay
III don't really have a great move
against III then okay let's trade Queens
yeah well okay the double pawns are of
course weakness but he's got the iphone
it shouldn't be rudi two were too
terrible for white so why not just III
yeah
you know he has Knight c3 to be five as
a possible idea it's something that I
need to be aware of I'm not sure if I
really should play Bishop f5 or move
like that developing out of outside of
the pawn chain yeah probably not it
takes lots of time and he's very good
with 95 I think I muster must play like
that it's not a big big issue this was
the idea preventing the night move for
the moment okay to yell to have six
probably
and now maybe Kingi 700d sexy okay no
this looks okay unless he's got
something something immediate here that
really set some specific direct problems
and I don't see it at the moment
yeah Bishop t6 is my next move if I'm if
it's my turn here yeah that's what weird
yeah what we should be six I wanted to
do anyway check just freeing the
position a bit by exchanging Knight to
c3 see intending night a 4 B 4 okay this
this looks okay in any case night a
five-night a5 was an interesting move
okay yeah well maybe I can still play
that next next month but ok can go
probably just Bishop c2 against that but
ok that's not exactly a great move
Bishop see to you know maybe maybe 9 a-5
is something that I need to consider I
think it's quite remarkable that is
actually playing more slowly than than I
am
okay yeah for to play this maybe night
rebooting the night would be six cents
wood beam is be 64 yeah that's also a
five but if I've does not look too well
timed okay yeah it's not not the type of
position where you can make huge huge
leaps forward just need you to improve
step by step ok might be 32 to c5 that's
a good idea
maybe I need you yeah he's content with
the draw yeah well I'm not here I'm not
really not but how to how to play maybe
this one okay I need to I need to do
something and avoid the direct
repetition
I don't know maybe as this is really
helping Emma getting rid of this is
somewhat weak pawn okay but if he takes
a ki can take with the night actually
intending that be three maybe I should
do that not not taking with rogue this
one yeah this leads to a more
interesting position I thought but came
right before was my original idea but it
didn't it's not really great yeah
hmm I don't be six hmm yeah while
avoiding the draw I got myself into some
trouble great
to get rid of this bloody night only
hope that are not mated with some some
cool stuff could happen my king is
really in some and it's in a bit of a
precarious situation yeah I was I was
more afraid of b6 now I get a night to
be sick so I place 94 also possible
ya think it's always funny that
sometimes you have people playing really
super passive chest doing nothing the
whole game and then at some point they
start to play really good moves like
g-form it's really really good move ok I
need I need to get some counter play and
I'll get some with Ruby for the ruckus
offside is very important it's not too
bad actually this position if you if you
ask me time morning because simply my
bishop is so much better threatening now
to take on b2 and then I have even some
chances to attack the king check check
check hmm this wasn't this wasn't great
not at all check check check luck for
fits on time really I just lost some
time he's got two one-hundredths of a
second mother clock ah don't you ever
tell me again that this game has
something to do with logic how came yeah
yeah he played this this nonsensical
moves to gain some sometime he is even
showing 000 on his clock would care but
whatever
I didn't really a pre move quick enough
it bit rusty with the pre wolves I what
the heck happened to him around here I'm
probably it's probably just about equal
disposition but I don't know I mean I
really I really played it badly I
shouldn't get into into trouble here and
I got into trouble hmm yeah yeah the
computer he actually finds a good
regrouping to not not happening all the
time but they good regrouping this this
is not helping much I am but yes it has
got a good idea playing this and using
v6 for night the night would be nicely
placed on d6 covering lots of crucial
squares like before c4b fire that's a
good regrouping it's a it's just an
equal position but this is this is a
good idea this yeah this is not great at
all I mean night before it is the more
solid choice but it didn't really seem
to me that I can play for a win which
which I wanted to do but of course this
is just just better for four wide yeah
yeah this is giving up on basically but
just a bad position and then you screwed
it up completely giving me the better
chances around here you need to play
more precise rook takes h7 that's not
good here here black isn't in good shape
again so of course matter of seconds on
the clock checked cannot
casper to to have yeah any precision him
this is this is of course okay check
okay for me on winning or whatever but
in the second really matter he he
managed to one time by check laying
those those checks I could have taken
the rook and stuff like that yeah well
it doesn't help to cry for for increment
all the time which really would stop
this nonsensical game finishes but with
just them as it is alright thanks for
watching